we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p our
voicemail line is made possible by our
good friends over at linguist which is a
language learning app that gauges your
personal skill level and your weaknesses
in the language you're trying to learn
it takes everything that we know about
neuroscience and memorization to build a
language learning program personalized
for you to optimize your language
learning journey i've been using it to
improve my french in advance of a return
to france later this year i love it you
can try it for free no credit card
required at ling viscom slash Pakman
that's linguist with a V dot comm slash
Pakman let's get to today's voice mail
with a very specific question about what
should Bernie Sanders do if he fails to
secure the 2020 Democratic Party
nomination
hey David this is Rick P from northern
New Jersey wanted to ask you a question
first time calling in big fan so my
question is should Bernie run as an
independent I'm not sure I'm thinking
that multiple people law has asked you
this question before but in that's
really my question as you as you know
DNC is not going to let him win so loved
it out here that's your answer is your
response to this question on your show
thanks Vicki soon bye bye okay so listen
Bernie Sanders should do whatever Bernie
Sanders determines is best and that
might mean best for him maybe that means
best for the country maybe that means
best for the American left however he
wants to sort of slice and dice it
Bernie Sanders can do if he does run as
an independent for whatever reason he is
making it more likely that Donald Trump
gets reelected because Bernie Sanders as
an independent is likely to in our
system of voting take away votes from
whoever is the Democratic nominee if
indeed it is not Bernie and by virtue of
that split the anti-trump vote making it
more likely that Donald Trump is
propelled to a second term now there may
be people who don't care
that there may be people who say if as
the caller suggests the DNC quote screws
Bernie and makes it so that a primary he
maybe would have won is won by somebody
else because of their meddling as
revenge as payback as the right thing to
do whatever maybe Bernie Sanders does
run as an independent and that we could
argue all day long whether idealism or
pragmatism should take precedence given
the disaster that is the mango Menace in
the Oval Office we could debate that all
day every day from now until November of
2020 but from a practical perspective
Bernie
running as a third-party candidate helps
Donald Trump secure reelection and at a
certain point you've got to ask the
pragmatic question beyond just the
idealism we have a great bonus show
today we will talk about Donald Trump
complaining that he didn't didn't get a
thank you for allowing John McCain's
funeral to happen Facebook is
apologizing after mistaking Donald
Trump's social media director for a bot
and Devin Nunez sued a Twitter account
dedicated to a cow that account now has
more Twitter followers than Devin Nunez
himself become a member at join
pakman.com get access to the bonus show
we'll speak to you that